have you noticed here on the internet
Bernie Sanders is everywhere a Wall
Street Wall Street and Wall Street are
you already this matters because in the
bedding for who will be the next
president Donald Trump the incumbent
leads but among Democrats senator
Sanders is among the top four thank you
all very much let's go forward together
and most people don't know that Sanders
has quietly built a digital media empire
that means he's in competition with me
and he's winning his videos come out
every few hours and they've been viewed
almost a billion times you were talking
about oligarchy many of his videos are
just him ranting about how Republican
ideas hurt people here he claims that
the repeal of Obamacare will kill
Americans tens of thousands of them will
die he ignores the thousands who may
live if the economy is allowed to grow
oh shut up silly woman said the reptile
with a grin other Sanders videos or
edited produced propaganda pieces you
knew damn well I was a snake before you
took be in here Sanders staff runs a
Trump speech where Trump quotes a song
about a woman who takes a snake into her
home and the snake then bites her Trump
uses it to take an unfair mean-spirited
swipe against immigrants while arguing
for tighter immigration controls Sanders
says every right to criticize that but
then he runs a clip suggesting that the
president calls all minority immigrants
animals animals this is the same kind of
language that the Nazis used but the
video never mentions that Trump's animal
comment was about the ms-13 gang another
consistent theme in Sanders videos is
that lots of people on the right are
horrible greedy people whose scheme to
get more money in this case by
abolishing the estate tax
a death packs they claim repeal will
save Trump four billion dollars and we
talk about a rigged economy he doesn't
mention that the estate tax taxes money
that was already taxed it's double
taxation he could still argue against
repeal but he ought to be fair many
Sanders videos demand that he make
College free because it's just too
expensive not just one or two people out
there who are saying like oh I can't
afford to go to college this is like the
majority of college students his staff
interviews themselves these are the
loans have really kept me from being
able to do things like purchase a home
again there's no mention of how existing
tuition subsidies already increased the
price of tuition and there's not a peep
about how his own wife's shady financial
dealings bankrupt at a college it's just
the government must pay more the cost of
education is just incredibly high and
you know somebody has to fit the bill
the government should assume that was my
school government should take
responsibility for your health care to
says this video which describes MSNBC
anchor Ali Velshi is a Canadian
capitalist nowhere on the face of the
earth is there a free health insurance
market that were stumped let's actually
bring that affordable and she'll make
one last family where there was never
affordable this is billed as a debate
but Republican Jim Jordan hardly gets
just say anything it's just one of those
areas that a free market doesn't work
it's easy to win an argument if you
never let the other guys speak almost
all new income and wealth is going to
the top one percent probably the biggest
theme in Bernie videos is income
inequality which Bernie says it's not
only immoral it is causing massive
suffering but he's just wrong the wealth
gap doesn't cause suffering yes rich
people got richer but the poor and
middle class got richer too Bernie
never says that and the pool are getting
poorer
Sanders posts a new economically
ignorant video most every day he says it
would be easy
to have free healthcare free college a
living wage
how will it be paid for simple raise
taxes tax me please please tax me
Sanders says the responsible rich want
to pay more I should be paying more in
taxes so pay more no one's stopping you
or give to charity charities will spend
your money better than government will
socialists think government's the
solution to every problem and they
pretend that what government provides is
free free education universal health
care a living wage Bernie's videos would
be just a joke except millions of people
walk and lots believe the nonsense he
preaches we look at these figures and we
say oh unemployment is low everything is
fine right well unemployment is low
because everyone has two jobs what
that's not how unemployment works I
don't know if she learned that from
Bernie but senator Sanders is the king
of economic ignorance the top 10% gets
it all gets it all and a billion people
watch you should know about that we'll
watch so you don't have to